Speaker 1: We also have a great David Pakman
Show subreddit where nearly 35000 of our viewers
are engaging in polite, respectful, non trolling
discussion of political issues. You can join the
discussion at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.
Many interesting posts I spotted, including some
people apologizing for having fallen for Tulsi
Gabbard. Here's one post from a user who says As
a veteran of two foreign wars, I took the bait for
her scam, hook, line and sinker. I'm anti-war and
I supported that message. I'm guilty of falling
for it and want to apologize to Sir Packman. Well,
I have not been knighted, so no reason to say sir.
Yeah, I mean, listen, you don't have to apologize
to me. It's just I think it would be great at
this point that Tulsi has gone full mask off
defending, defending Russia over the last couple
of days and just crazy crazy. Check out my Twitter
for some of her recent wacky statements. It's just
great to realize if you were duped, you were duped
and know you are susceptible to being duped, and
that will hopefully protect you better in the
future. That, I think is is what you know. I don't
need an apology. It's just let's all recognize
how did it happen and how can I prevent myself
inoculate myself from being duped again?
Another user says. Get you someone who speaks
to you the way David speaks to the people from
Europe. I love when we get calls from
Europe, I find it interesting. I find
it interesting that we have people in other
countries that pay attention to the show.
And if it's a part of Europe I've been to, I love
reminiscing about when I used to travel to Europe,
which has not has not happened for some time other
than the Spain trip, which sort of went horribly
wrong a few months ago. But we don't really talk
about that anymore, but we love our callers from
the United States as well. Of course, they make up
the majority of our audience. Lastly, another user
on the subreddit points out, Why do I get so many
right wing shorts on YouTube? Almost everyone I'm
subscribed to is liberal, but almost all my shorts
are right wing. Not saying I just want to be in a
left wing bubble, but it's kind of weird. This
is not. So here's what's going on with YouTube
shorts. It's mostly right wingers producing
YouTube shorts. YouTube Shorts is a new short form
vertical video format similar to Instagram
Reels, similar to TikToks, and it is mostly
being used on YouTube by the right wing. So we
started producing shorts a couple of months ago,
and we are continuing to build, and I encourage
every other left wing show start producing and
publishing shorts. We can't let the right control
the format, and the reason you're getting so many
right wing shorts is it's mostly right wingers
producing them. And we're now doing one or two
a day and we're going to keep going with it.
We can't cede these platforms to the right.
Join the discussion on the David Pakman Show
subreddit David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.